m
bonsoir le 7-8 sûreté défilent comme
chaque soir du lundi au jeudi une heure
pour faire le tour de l'actualité locale
en direct de 18 à 19 heures aujourd'hui
mardi 19 mars je reçois daniel varlet
bonsoir vous êtes le président de la
chambre des métiers et de l'artisanat
dans le département des yvelines avec
vous nous reviendrons sur cette semaine
de l'artisanat avec un point sur ce
secteur d'activité dans le département
des yvelines ce sera dans quelques
instants auparavant nous allons
découvrir ensemble les titres du jour
les reportages que nous allons vous
proposer ce soir sujet de la rédaction
la semaine nationale de l'artisanat donc
dans les yvelines avec plusieurs
manifestations au programme dont ce
break déj ce midi pour faire se
rencontrer des dirigeants nouvellement
installée est tous les détails à suivre
l des voyageurs insatisfaits et qui le
font savoir une pétition circule en ce
moment sur la ligne de carre
saint-quentin-en-yvelines poissy pour
réclamer notamment de meilleures
fréquences plus de cent signatures
recueillies pour l'espace d'une petite
semaine
la commémoration du 19-mars dorénavant à
date officielle de célébration de la fin
de cette guerre avec le cessez-le-feu en
algérie dont se réjouissent et les
associations d'anciens combattants ce
matin a notamment à la verrière les
ondes électromagnétiques et ses dangers
potentiels et stéphane loriot chargée
d'animation au sein du parc naturel de
la haute vallée de chevreuse il est
hyper sensibles aux ondes
il va nous raconter tout à l'heure son
quotidien est d'ailleurs cette
thématique nous allons l'aborder aussi
au cours de la chronique de
l'environnement avec julie rocha soirée
ce qu'on soit revu les bons soirs donc
nous allons en effet nous intéresser aux
ondes électromagnétiques et leurs
conséquences sur notre santé et nous
recevons pour cela rosine rowland
présidente de l'association arc
chevreuse qui luttent contre le
déploiement des antennes relais de
téléphonie mobile à la chronique de
l'environnement avec cette question des
électrosensibles ce sera dans une
vingtaine de minutes dans le set suite
à noter également que je recevrai ce
soir deux associations qui font preuve
de solidarité
l'association rêves tout d'abord qui
intervient auprès d'enfants malades mais
aussi le rotaract club qui fédère des
jeunes qui souhaitent tout simplement
aider leur prochain rotaract club de
versailles plus précisément avant de
s'intéresser à la semaine de l'artisanat
donc cette information également
omar sy et pour la troisième fois la
personnalité préférée des 7-14 ans et un
sondage ipsos qui l'affirment est déjà
la personnalité préférée des français
des adultes cette fois ci elle le natif
de trappes qui a décroché un césar pour
intouchables qui figurent aussi au
casting du prochain film blockbuster
américain
x-men est suivi dans ce classement d'un
autre hybride noah d'un autre trappistes
jamais le blues il est à la dixième
place
le classement sera complet sera à
découvrir demain dans le journal de
mickey et oui on peut aussi s'informer
dans le journal de mickey
voilà pour ce petit clin d'oeil on passe
à présent aux faits du jour et
l'artisanat acquise il était qui est à
l'honneur par mois et depuis le 15 mars
et jusqu'au 22 mars se tient donc la
semaine de l'artisanat et un chiffre à
présent le chiffre de cette édition qui
s'affiche un peu plus d'un million c'est
le nombre d'entreprises artisanales
recensés en france et c'est la direction
générale de la compétitivité de
l'industrie et des services qui avant ce
chiffre je pourrais également cité
d'autres toujours de la même source
l'artisanat qui emploie plus de 3
millions de personnes en france un
secteur qui a généré plus de 100
milliards d'euros de valeur ajoutée en
2010 une hausse de 3,6 pour cent en un
an daniel varlet vous êtes donc le
président de l'artisanat dans ce
département des yvelines
les chiffres sont plutôt bons
l'artisanat se porte bien au niveau
national c'est aussi le cas dans le
département
l'artisanat ce1 se porte bien oui nous
sommes néanmoins en crise mais nous
voulons avoir une parole positive
d'ailleurs le
les motifs de cette semaine de
l'artisanat c'est parole d'artisans afin
de laisser parler deux artisans car
malgré la crise nous sommes quand même
les les des employeurs et nous sommes
des artisans est content de nos
entreprises et quelque part nous voulons
avoir c'est ce côté positif des choses
et je rappelle que vous êtes président
depuis le début de cette année celui
mangin pour un mandat de trois ans vous
avez été élu très récemment vous étiez
trésorier ou pas j'ai été trésorier dans
l'ancienne mandature de cette chambre de
métiers maintenant voilà président
depuis le 16 mars dernier
alors vous qui est aujourd'hui président
dans quel état vous vous trouvez
justement l'artisanat aujourd'hui dans
le département je citais quelques
chiffres tout à l'heure 3 millions de
personnes en france va plus d'un million
également de d'entreprises artisanales
recensé quelque elle mesure pour ce
département d alors pour pour le
département des yvelines nous sommes
mille dix sept mille dix sept mille
entreprises sort se fait donc dix sept
mille chefs d'entreprise ça fait trente
trois mille salariés ça fait 2000 120
apprentis dans nos centres de formation
voilà les chiffres les chiffres du
département ça représente une entreprise
sur cinq
quand vous dites que vous rencontrez
aussi des difficultés ce sont de quelle
nature des entreprises artisanales qui
disparaissent les réduisent les
effectifs en tout cas elles réduisent
elles maintiennent les effectifs puisque
nous sommes des entreprises de taille
familiale et on est respectueux de nos
de nos salariés
donc on prend sur nos propres marges
bénéficiaires pour maintenir l'emploi on
on ne permet pas joli des grès sport
chez les messieurs on aime bien nos
collaborateurs néanmoins c'est en
prenant un petit peu sur nos marges que
l'on arrive à passer ce cap difficile de
il ya beaucoup de professions qui sont
regroupés derrière ce terme d'artisanal
la profession la plus courante chez les
professions qui tourne autour du
bâtiment
en tout cas au niveau national
l'artisanat ses quatre pôles différence
et la fabrication la production c'est le
bâtiment c les services et c'est aussi
l'alimentation
voilà les cales paul de l'artisanat et
l'alimentation dont vous êtes issus
d'ailleurs je suis charcutier en effet
maître artisan charcutier on peut
peut-être justement s'intéresser à votre
parcours
donc pourquoi vous avez choisi
l'artisanat vous dire je suis le
troisième de la génération d'artisans
dans la famille je suis né à faire de ce
troisième charcutier c'est compte tenu
de mes antécédents que baigné dans le
syndicalisme et dans dans l'artisan que
je me suis senti obligé d'aider un petit
peu mes collègues le point fort de
l'artisanat aussi c'est peut-être
l'arrivée dans la profession via
l'apprentissage
alors c est ce qu on en parle on a un
cursus très très particulier mais qui
s'ouvre absolument à tout le monde
puisque on apprend
les formations chez nous c'est en
alternance est une semaine dans les cfa
et trois semaines en entreprise dès
l'âge de 15 ans et à 6 a fait un
ascenseur social pour pour nos jeunes
ils apprennent petit à petit alors au
début ils apprennent le métier mise
apprennent aussi à se conduire en
entreprise puisque je vous dis c'est en
retail familiale donc on est un petit
peu les pères de famille quand ils
arrivent chez nous parce qu'ils sont
encore un petit peu jeune et des ans -
ils ravissent progressivement les
échelons et on arrive maintenant avoir
des formations jusqu'au niveau niveau
que 3 commence à quel âge à peu près on
commence à 15 saisons les apprentissages
autour de 16 ans segment ils sont encore
jeunes et ce sont des pères de famille
alors d'ailleurs vous dites père de
famille c'est une profession très
masculine oui plutôt et plutôt plutôt
masculine mais comment ça s'explique que
dans l'artisanat il ya plus d'hommes que
de femmes est-ce que ça a évolué aussi
alors l'artisanat était dans le temps
des métiers durs
alors qu'ils sont enfin ils se sont
mécanisés ils se sont vraiment facilité
maintenant mais c'est vrai dans le temps
l'artisanat était réputé pour des
métiers durs loin tout ça alors que ça
s'est matérialisé ça s'est beaucoup
beaucoup de machines nous n maintenant
et l'artisanat c'est le plaisir de le
plaisir de travailler parce que on a
plein de gens qui sont épanouis dans
leur dans leur profession et et on gagne
sa vie dans l'artisanat et dans
l'artisanat parmi les chefs d'entreprise
plus de trois quarts en france sont des
hommes voilà pour les quelques chiffres
on évoquait les les métiers de
l'artisanat justement alors qu évoque
l'artisanat pour vous c'est la question
que nous sommes allez vous poser
c'est l'une de nos questions du jour
micro-trottoir l'artisanat ça m'évoque
la poterie celui voc des anciens métiers
on voit plus beaucoup d'aujourd'hui va
de la coiffure ça qui peut être de l'art
la mode la fabrication de bijoux voilà
et menuisiers des plombiers des terrains
au titre de société menuisier carreleurs
plombiers
tous ces petits métiers manuels savoir
faire manuel a deux
des objets faits main c'est vraiment le
savoir faire français quelconque connaît
qu'ils se soient rurales ou ou même
urbain c'est vraiment pour moi le ce qui
permet de dynamiser l'économie en france
daniel verlet un mot qui est revenu
assez souvent finalement dans ce micro
trottoir c'est le mot savoir faire
absolument un savoir-faire l'artisanat
l'artisanat c'est l'art c'est l'art de
faire et comme le dit bien le reportage
les gens sont plus attentifs mais c'est
ont fait de nos mains donc nous sommes
des arts dans l'artisanat
aujourd'hui bien justement c'est cette
bonne image de l'artisanat je pense
qu'on re d'or l'image sont là les gens
là retrouve un petit peu au travers de
professionnels qui assurent une certaine
sécurité auprès de leur clientèle
puisqu'il nous faut des jambes à un
artisan il efface avoué les face à face
à son client et c'est un rapprochement
qui je pense sécurisé maintenant les
relations entre les clients et le savoir
faire des artisans
même si quelquefois il ya des
difficultés qui sont rencontrés aussi
lorsqu'on fait appel peut-être à
certains artisans on peut pas se
revendiquer tout le monde ne peut pas se
revendiquer aussi l'artisan toutes les
personnes qui s'installent à leur compte
par exemple je pense aux plombiers qu'on
entendait tout à l'heure ça rentrait
dans la caricature mais lorsqu'on
rencontre des difficultés avec certaines
personnes qui se revendique artisans
vous en tant que représentant de la
chambre des métiers de l'artisanat vous
surveillez aussi vous faites attention à
l image qui est véhiculée par certaines
personnes certains c'est là tout le
dilemme de la chambre de métiers tout le
dilemme de du président sait qu'on doit
inscrire absolument tout le monde comme
artisan on a pas lieu de sélectionner
donc on doit les inscrire mais après je
dirais que c'est par le travail lui-même
de l'artisan qui fait qui fera sa
réputation et qui va continuer à être
pérennisé dans son métier mais vous vous
n'avez aucun moyen de le surveiller
contrôler intervenaient
non c'est un regret peut-être absolument
puisque je voudrais que tous les
artisans soyez entièrement responsables
de ce qu'ils font et même l'artisan qui
est pas tout à fait dans les cordes
maintenant il ya des moyens de formation
il peut il peut s'informer il peut se
former et il a tout l'été où les outils
nécessaires pour faire le vrai et le bon
artisan set cette semaine la semaine de
l'artisanat l'artisanat l'artisanat qui
est mis en avant à travers notamment le
département des yvelines vous organiser
plusieurs rendez vous il y en a eu
aujourd'hui un break déj cinquième
rendez-vous ce cinquième break déj ça
consiste en quoi on va se rendre dans un
instant sur place justement on va voir
le reportage les dans les grandes lignes
alors le break d'âge
c'est un c'est une idée de notre service
eco c'est la cinquième édition
on invite les créateurs de moins de
trois ans à venir se retrouver à la
chambre des métiers à l'occasion alors
leur fait une petite conférence sur sur
manager ou sur le les différents
différentes point de conférence c'est
aujourd'hui c'était comment bien vente
savoir vendre ses produits et après on
voudrait former une sorte de réseau il
ya un échange de cartes de visite de
relations de et les gens se côtoient
entre eux et ainsi ils se sécurise entre
eux ils échangent les adresses et
et ç'a eu beaucoup de succès mais si
aujourd'hui on était près d'une 81 100
personnes qui sont venues à sevrey
demande dès lors comment s'est déroulé
ce break days justement nous allons le
voir en images reportages de la
rédaction
il y a fool à la chambre des métiers et
de l'artisanat une centaine de jeunes
dirigeants a répondu présent aubrac déj
annuelle organisée dans le cadre de la
semaine de l'artisanat
au programme une conférence sur la
performance commerciale
nicolas caron spécialiste de la
formation en management commercial était
venu transmettre son savoir faire à la
salle était comble donc les gens sont
toujours intéressés de savoir comment
comment convaincre de nouveaux clients
en étant qu'ils sont un petit peu
difficile donc l'idée c'était de revenir
son délire sur des fondamentaux sur des
idées clés ne pas trop stresser
vis-à-vis du résultat que des toits
seront en activité commerciale du mal à
maîtriser mais voir quel est le chemin
alors les objectifs de performance
plutôt d'objectifs de résultats et des
résultats ces jeunes dirigeants sont
demandeurs car c'est bien lors des
premières années que les entreprises
sont le plus fragile leur apporter un
éclairage sur un aspect essentiel de la
gestion d'entreprise mais peu maîtrisée
par les artisans
tel était le but de la chambre des
métiers de l'artisanat les artistes ont
connaissent très bien leur métier c'est
le principe de base
maintenant le métier de chef
d'entreprise il est
à multiples facettes est une des plus
dures c'est le commercial donc comment
trouver un client aujourd'hui c'est pas
inné lorsqu'on a été salarié pendant
cinq dix quinze ans bah c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on apprend forcément
donc le commercial c'est peut-être ce
qui est plus dur
ces artisans sont donc venus glaner des
informations mais prend des notes et on
tend l'oreille comme ça un peu la crise
on sait pas comment aller chercher le
client compris donc on voulait des
informations pour paraître plus pointus
comme ils disent l'intervenant
m'intéressait c'est tout ce qui est
prospection commerciale donc c'est
forcément très intéressant quand on
débute
et puis aussi rencontrer enfin élargir
un petit peu de réseau et rencontrer
d'autres artisans pour partager un peu
nos problématiques et les villes nos
entreprises qui débutent l'importance du
réseau un sujet bien connu de la chambre
de métiers et de l'artisanat qui
proposait à la suite de la conférence un
déjeuner ou dirigeant élu de la chambre
mais aussi partenaires bancassurance
experts ont pu échanger et lors de ce
rendez-vous vous l'avez aperçu justement
dans le reportage vous l'avez entendu
même nicolas caron qui était présent il
est l'auteur d'ouvragés sur l'efficacité
commerciale vendre aux clients
difficiles c'est le titre de son livre
il tenait une conférence sur la
performance commerciale
voici trois conseils qu'il donne aux
artisans premier conseil identifier
quelles sont les étapes clés de sa
performance commerciale ne pas se
focaliser uniquement sur le réseau mais
décortiquer les choses de façon à savoir
très clairement quels sont les
différents gestes que je dois bien faire
pour être plus efficace et la fin de
l'année
deuxième conseil c'est de prendre du
recul
les temps sont difficiles donc
évidemment il ya des échecs n'arrivent
pas toujours à ses fins du premier coup
le le bon commercial c'est celui qui
s'est approché à les apprivoiser les
chèques
celui qui sait se remettre d'une
difficulté et qui continue donc c'est
une composante à important dans le field
et commercial et puis le troisième parce
que je pourrais vous dire le troisième
c'est apprendre apprendre tout s'apprend
il ya des tas de choses qui peuvent être
apprises et travailler et si on
décompose bien les choses on arrive à se
transformer à changer et des gens qui
aujourd'hui pourrait se déclarer pas
très bons en commerciales sont tout à
fait capable de faire de bons résultats
la fin d'année mais il faut apprendre
faut donner les moyens
le ronflement c'est finalement une
attention sur les chemins tous les
chemins peuvent être différents dans
leurs particularités des métiers qui
étaient dans la salle
maintenant ce qui est commun c'est ce
sont les les étapes les standards avant
de signer une affaire il faut que sa
proposition soit de qualité pour faire
des propositions de qualité encore
faut-il pouvoir émettre des propositions
pour mettre des propositions quand
faut-il avoir la bombe de rendez-vous
suffisant pour des rendez-vous faisant
prendre des rendez vous donc savoir
téléphoner savoir réseauter donc sur
chacune de ces étapes c'est sur les
quelques repères que j'essaie de donner
pour que je sois cul de ces étapes les
gens soient meilleurs demain qu'il aime
il sentira bien d'apporter notre savoir
est-ce qu'on va retirer
c'est toujours cette touche très riche
et très très enthousiasmant parce qu'on
voit des gens qui sont pas obligés de
venir
la salle était comble donc c'est un
sujet qui intéresse beaucoup de gens
donc moi c'est un vrai plaisir chez la
science de ne pas travailler je fais
quelque chose qui me passionne
donc le partager avec autant de gens qui
qui sont à l'écouté et c'est un plaisir
nicolas caron interviewé par claire
cambier pour tv fil 78 nous parlons donc
de la semaine de l'artisanat et pour
conclure au delà de ce rendez vous qui
s'est déroulé aujourd'hui de ce break
days cinquième édition quels sont les
autres rendez-vous à attendre d'ici la
fin de la semaine
j'ai bien un autre centre de formation
d'apprentis samedi et dimanche matin les
portes seront ouvertes afin que nos
jeunes et les parents puissent venir
voir les formations dans l'artisanat
puisque nous avons un centre d'apprentis
en fait très en forme sur trets douze
métiers différents et donc ça sera
l'occasion aux jeunes de se rendre
compte de pousser la porte pour les
quelques quelques jeunes qui se sont
inquiets de leur avenir mais il faut
avoir quand même une certaine passion
une certaine vocation il faut pas faut
pas venir là faut avoir une petite idée
et non je les invite bien sûr à pousser
la porte du cfa de versailles samedi ou
dimanche prochain ainsi ils pourront
toucher pourront voir et puis
communiquer avec nos formateurs quelles
sont les filières qui attire le plus la
formation qui séduit le plus la coiffure
l'esthétique la boucherie
ce sont des formations qu'on dispense là
et c'est vraiment un paradoxe que vous
voyez en boucherie
on manque au moins deux jeunes dans les
boucheries on manquera deux repreneurs
plus tard puisqu'il faut savoir que
d'autres formations c'est pour pouvoir
transmettre nos métiers mais c'est aussi
transmettre notre passion mais c'est
aussi former nos futurs repreneurs et on
a un manque énorme au niveau de la
boucherie boulangerie ça va mieux
pâtisseries ont rempli les effectifs
mais néanmoins il ya encore beaucoup de
place dans nos jeunes et dans nos
métiers donc n'hésitez pas à vous rendre
à ces portes ouvertes si vous cherchez
des filières qui embauchent et c'est
plutôt rassurant c'est un petit peu
difficile merci daniel verlet donc
d'être venu sur ce plateau la semaine de
l'artisanat qui se termine le 22 mars la
suite du 7-8 avec une association qui
réalise les rêves des enfants dans une
quinzaine de minutes également la
chronique de l'environnement consacrée à
l'électro sensibilité aimait déjà retour
sur l'actualité du jour pour la première
fois la date du 19 mars a permis de
commémorer les victimes du conflit
algérien aussi bien côté français que
côté algérien retour sur la cérémonie
organisée ce matin à la verrière julie
rocha soirée c'est elodie mois l'ancien
soldat familles et proches ont tenu à se
rassembler au cimetière de la verrière
ce 19,6 pour ne pas oublier les victimes
civiles et militaires de la guerre
d'algérie
la date de commémoration divisent mais
cette journée nationale du souvenir et
du recueillement et pour la première
fois officiel cinquante et une années
après le cessez-le-feu mais c'est
surtout pour les anciens combattants
mais moi je suis veuve d'ancien
combattant
et c'est une reconnaissance et une
officialisation depuis la fin de la
guerre d'algérie que tous les anciens
combattants attendaient pour l'occasion
la fnaca de maurepas qui fête ses 40 ans
cette année a mis en place une
exposition de témoignages intitulé no 20
en afrique du nord à l'étagé de l'hôtel
de ville de mort pas les premiers
tableaux évoquent le départ des soldats
de marseille pour l'algérie
la découverte des paysages et de la vie
des bédouins mais pas seulement
on voit des photos d'eux
des interventions qui sont interviennent
par exemple dans les gorges de palestro
on aperçoit également à l'aller comment
dirais-je la pacification
on voit également qu'à pacification
c'était aussi la guerre mais c'était
aussi le service de l'armée auprès des
populations des services comme les soins
médicaux
gérald ed ce coffre a été appelé pour la
pacification de mars 1956 à mars 1958
dans le groupe d'hélicoptères numéro
deux avec un lieu de nos médecins il
faisait des tournées dans les villages
isolés
il se souvient donc il ya le pad et
réciter des lampes à pétrole et une fois
la lampe a été renversé et la petite
fille a été très très gravement brûlée
qui a permis bain par l'intermédiaire
des hélicoptères mais sur de l'emmener
toute fuite à l'hôpital de sétif et
j'assure les revues un an après été
sauvés l'exposition de la fnac à
maurepas se termine ce samedi